[Applaudissements]
je voudrais commencer cette intervention
par une petite question je voudrais vous
demander pour vous éveillez peut-être
combien voyez-vous de triangle dans
cette image je vous écoute cette allée
dose de huit cinémas qui voit plus de 12
1 16
bon là la vraie réponse la bonne réponse
c'est effectivement 0 il n'y a aucun
triangle dans cette image tout
simplement parce qu'il n'ya aucun
triangle fini comme vous le voyez c'est
bien l'éducation de notre oeil qui nous
fait fermer les images qui nous font
voir en fait des triangles là où il y en
a pas et donc dans cette intervention
pour moi prendre large ça va être
prendre un peu de distance pour réaliser
qu'en fait et bien les formes sont loin
d'être finie ça touche nos stéréotypes
sa touche nos approches de la réalité et
vous allez voir comment est ce que pour
moi le théâtre va vous permettre de
pouvoir toucher à ce large à cette
largesse aussi d'infinies possibilités
de vivre sa vie un petit mot sur le
théâtre
un petit mot sur ma passion pour le
théâtre j'ai commencé par le
conservatoire et puis après avoir
terminé a brillamment je me suis
retrouvé dans la possibilité de passer
des castings pour des publicités ou
alors éventuellement me déguiser en mini
pour des soirées d'anniversaire
je me suis donc dit et serait peut-être
intéressant de voir
d'une certaine manière pourquoi est ce
qu'on m'a appris à bien dire et surtout
les tics de cette parole sur scène
pourquoi est-ce que je suis sur scène et
pourquoi j'essaie de défendre des idées
qui bien sûr ne sont pas les miennes en
tant qu'interprète j'ai rencontré alors
des producteurs et je leur ai dit que
j'aurais aimé pouvoir partager des
techniques théâtrales avec des personnes
qui en ont besoin des personnes qui
n'ont pas ce savoir faire
à l'époque j'étais très intéressé par
les rescapés du génocide du rwanda et
mon rêve c'était de pouvoir travailler
avec eux et de pouvoir les mettre en
scène contre la désinformation pour les
aider à mieux dire les producteurs que
j'ai rencontrés m'ont regardé avec un
air très dubitatif et m'ont demandé si
j'avais un budget c'est là où je suis
resté absolument effarés en leur
demandant si c'était le nom d'une pièce
de théâtre que je n'avais pas lu et ils
m'ont répondu allez apprendre et j'ai
été à prendre à l'échec à l'essec école
bien aimé où j'ai appris le bonheur de
la comptabilité de la finance entre
autres en essayant toujours de parier
sur les points pour avoir mes cours
fondamentaux tâche très difficile et
finalement j'ai réussi à les avoir et
suit à moins un billet j'ai commencé à
produire mes propres spectacles mettre
en scène en particulier donc ces
rescapés du rwanda et puis je suis tombé
sur une pièce de théâtre qui m'a
bouleversé une pièce de théâtre qui
s'appelle le procès de cham gorod c'est
une pièce qui a été écrite par elie
wiesel et qui met dieu en procès pour ce
qui s'est passé pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
pour ce qui s'est passé pendant la shoah
je me suis dit c'est absolument génial
voilà un témoin une victime un rescapé
qui utilisent le théâtre pour mieux dire
et qui en plus a le culot de pouvoir
enfermé la divinité sur scène et je lui
ai écrit je lui ai écrit à l'université
de boston puisque c'était là où il
enseignait et je lui ai demandé si je
pouvais l'interviewer et à ce propos
pour qu'il m'explique pourquoi il avait
utilisé le théâtre je ne le connaissais
pas un peu comme on en voit une
bouteille à la mer et il m'a répondu
il m'a répondu qu'il avait écrit
plusieurs pièces de théâtre en
particulier dans sa jeunesse mais que
ses éditeurs me trouvais pas intéressant
de les publier
il ouvrit il ouvrirait ses archives pour
que je puisse travailler sur ces pièces
de théâtre s'il était intéressé et
finissent est il dans la lettre il
deviendrait mon directeur de thèse 6
je le souhaitais je le souhaitais donc
je suis parti pendant sept ans à
l'université de boston où j'ai travaillé
avec lui sur comment dire comment mieux
dire
pourquoi dire toutes ces questions en
particulier sur scène contre le
négationnisme contre la désinformation
et au bout de sept ans j'ai mis en place
une sorte de méthode théâtrale par le
non verbal et le verbal pour aider la
personne à mieux s'exprimer sur scène je
suis parti après pendant un an et demi
j'ai travaillé je suis parti à sarajevo
pour aider des survivants à mieux
s'exprimer j'ai pu travailler avec des
personnes victimes en particulier de
violence sur la question de l'excision
jusqu'à ce que harvard université soit
au courant du travail que j'ai fait et
me demande de venir créer un cours qui
s'appelle théâtre et droits de l'homme
en 2012 j'ai la chance d'être nommé pour
un spectacle que je fais aux nations
unies artiste de l'unesco pour la paix
ce qui me permet de pouvoir travailler
avec un réseau qui est assez conséquent
lorsque je suis à revoir d'université et
bien j'ai la chance de pouvoir suivre
tous les cours que je veux j'ai choisi
de faire un post doctorat et dans les
cours que je choisis il ya secours sur
le bonheur d'un certain talent ben sahar
je sais pas si vous le connaissez qui
est le chantre de la psychologie
positive
un cours qui est très apprécié à harvard
et étudiants et je suis ce que je suis
un peu bouleversé par les différentes
techniques mais qui restent encore
profondément intellectuelle je vais le
voir après le court et je lui dis
comment on pourrait faire pour faire
descendre toute cette masse de savoir
comment on pourrait faire pour ancrer
mieux dans le corps toutes ces questions
pourquoi est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
travailler sur du non verbal ou du
verbal imaginez des exercices théâtraux
pour que les personnes puissent vraiment
vivre une psychologie positive habité et
il accepte il accepte de me faire
confiance et il va m'ouvrir les portes
du coaching
j'avais alors être très inspiré par
trois rencontres que je vais faire
harvard université talent belchard que
vous voyez au centre de cette image
qu'il est professeur en psychologie
positive
mais aussi william oury qui est le
chantre du programme négocié chaîne
c'est lui qui a écrit le très célèbre
livre getting to yes et puis ma rge
rhinolophe qui est les spécialistes
exécutive communications skype
ces trois personnalités vous me
permettre de pouvoir développer toute
une série d'exercices non verbaux et
verbaux autour de la négociation de la
communication et de la psychologie
positive
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'avoir
beaucoup de clients et j'interviens à la
fois en france et aux états unis à
boston et à paris essentiellement et
vous voyez que non seulement il ya des
enseignes que vous connaissez dans le
monde privé mais aussi du service public
avec l'ena l'école de la magistrature ou
encore le secrétariat général pour la
modernisation de l'action publique
le sg map donc ce soir j'aimerais que
nous puissions terminer ce tedx en
faisant quelques exercices que je fais
faire en cours des exercices que je fais
dans le département de négociation de
psychologie positive et de communication
ces exercices seront très rapides mais
je l'espère efficace premier exercice
fait vous demander de trouver un binôme
donc de vous retourner vers la personne
la plus proche de vous voilà en face à
face
allez allez on joue le jeu on se bouge
c'est pas parce qu'il est arc
voilà et de pouvoir et bien simplement
suivre l'indication de l'image c'est à
dire mettre sa main dans celle de son
partenaire sa partenaire en mettant son
coût de plus ou moins sur l'accoudoir je
sais que normalement il doit y avoir une
table mais là ya pas de table donc on
met le coude sur l'accoudoir vous êtes
prêts l'idée est la suivante
à chaque fois que vous faites un point
vous allez réussir à mettre votre main
ou celle de l'adversaire le plus proche
de l'accoudoir d'accord comme c'est un
petit peu mal installé on va dire aux
trois quarts du coude
de l'autre on considère que c'est un
point et le but est de faire le maximum
de points possibles je compte 15
secondes
vous êtes prêts c'est parti
tout
top on s'arrête alors combien de
personnes ont fait entre 0 et 5 point
levé la main on va dire la majorité très
bien entre 5 et 10 points s'il vous
plaît on lève la main plus de dix points
à bah oui ce qui connaît bien sûr alors
comment on fait pour avoir plus de dix
points c'est à dire en fait gagner le
jeu c'est très simple on accepte la
collaboration plutôt que de rentrer dans
un bras de fer et essayer de se mesurer
à l'autre comme compétiteur comme
concurrents eh bien on accepte de
comprendre les règles du jeu c'est à
dire faire le maximum de points en
allées et venues ou alors d'un côté ou
de l'autre
d'accord ça permet de mieux comprendre
le sens le sens du verbe convaincre qui
n'a rien à voir avec l'idée de rallier
quelqu'un quelquefois malgré lui à sa
propre opinion mais qui au contraire se
base sur l'idée du coum vie quéré
c'est-à-dire vaincre ensemble ça c'est
un des exercices par exemple que l'on
fait dans le programme de négociations
un autre exercice à présent au tour de
la psychologie positive
il faut savoir que vous êtes nous sommes
tous responsables de notre propre
bonheur qu'est ce que c'est que la
psychologie positive
eh bien elle part du principe que plutôt
que de se tourner comme le fait à la
fois on va dire toutes les sciences qui
touche la médecine et la psychologie en
particulier plutôt que de se tourner sur
la question du symptôme vers le malade
eh bien on se tourne vers ce qui marche
vers les personnes qui disent qu'elles
vont bien et on essaye d'en tirer des
conclusions à partir de là on se rend
compte que la plupart des personnes on
parle pas bien sûr des personnes qui
sont atteintes de maladies chroniques
mais la plupart des personnes et biens
peuvent être responsables de leur degré
de bonheur comme vous le voyez sur
l'image suivante et bien 50% et
prédéterminés mais il reste encore 10
pour
en deux circonstances extérieures à nous
et surtout 40 % d'activité volontaires
c'est-à-dire qu'il dépend vraiment que
de nous de pouvoir accepter d'être
heureux ou pas c'est à dire que c'est un
vrai exercice journalier qu'il faut
pouvoir est bien acceptée pour être un
peu plus chaque jour donc l'exercice est
le suivant j'ai demandé à un courageux
allez on va dire au cinquième rang un
courageux de se lever
oui oui pourra il pourra je vois qu'au
cinquième rang on a des velléités de de
se lever à les deux bouts ça met du
temps mais ça vient allez allez
voilà très bien voyez je vais demander à
cette personne valeureuse et courageuse
de pouvoir nous dire
trois adjectifs positif sur lui même
nous écoutons aider le taisez vous non
j'ai pas dis que j'ai pas dit que
d'autres parlent pour lui j'ai dit que
lui nous disent trois adjectifs positifs
et si les timides c'est encore mieux oui
curieux organisé
merci à l'ecoute voyez pas beaucoup de
prise de risques très bien et maintenant
cette personne reste debout et va devoir
soutenir non pas nos critiques parce
qu'après tout ça c'est facile mais nos
applaudissements
pendant trente secondes c'est parti
oui
à l'entente
vous pouvez vous rasseoir merci beaucoup
vous avez eu votre dose pour ce soir
alors généralement dans certaines
classes de psychologie positive on porte
la personne vraiment vraiment en l'air
ça fait un drôle d'effet mais je vous
assure que les personnes se rappellent
de ça et en termes de confiance en soi
ça aide
on passe maintenant un dernier exercice
un exercice de tests psychologiques
vous avez dû tous se recevoir un
programme je vous demander de prendre le
programme est de prendre un crayon pour
que vous puissiez et bien révéler
quelque chose de votre personnalité
pas beaucoup de place une petite partie
blanche suffira c'est bon alors voilà ce
que vous allez devoir faire sur cette
petite partie blanche de votre programme
je vais vous demander en haut à gauche
de faire un rond en dessous un carré
dans l'es4 suivre l'image c'est plus
facile
en dessous le triangle et puis en
vis-à-vis à losanges 3 auront du plus
petit au plus grand et une croix
vous êtes prêts vous allez avoir trente
secondes pour compléter chaque forme
pour que cela puisse donner une image
c'est à dire par exemple le cercle vous
fait d'être et autour et ça devient un
soleil
d'accord le triangle bien vous faites un
très en dessous vous faites un point
d'exclamation ça donne un panneau au
code de la route
bon je vous donne pas d'autre sinon je
vous influencerait je vous donne pas
d'autres exemples
et à côté de chaque forme je veux que
vous écriviez un mot ce mot peut être
relatifs à la forme que vous venez de
compléter ou pas vraiment tout ce qui
vous passe par la tête et le plus
rapidement possible pour les personnes
qui n'ont pas d'imagination
faites-le quand même vous êtes prêts
c'est parti
il vous reste dix secondes
ça doit être vraiment quelque chose de
très premier g1 vraiment du brouillon
c'est bon stop on arrête je vais
maintenant vous dire à quoi correspond
chaque forme
la première correspond à votre rapport
au monde comment vous vous situez
vis-à-vis du monde extérieur est aussi
votre personnalité la forme la plus on
va dire habituel c'est un smiley
d'accord marqué heureux la deuxième
forme correspond à votre image du foyer
comment est ce que vous percevez votre
chez vous la forme la plus ordinaire que
les personnes font on l'a remarqué
c'est une maison à la troisième forment
le triangle c'est votre conception de
l'amitié sent déjà que les conceptions
bizarre la forme la plus habituelle que
l'on voit c'est une pyramide avec brique
après brique ou alors comment construire
une amitié ou alors des personnes ont
fait une petite tête en dessous du
trille ans qui devient un chapeau parce
que leur conception de l'amitié c'est de
faire la fête
le losange conception de l'argent si
vous avez fait un cerf-volant
c'est la figure qui revient le plus
enfin les trois bulles amour et
sexualité
généralement les personnes font une
famille avec un petit bonhomme une maman
et un papa
enfin ça dépend de votre conception de
la sexualité
et puis elle la dernière forme
géométrique la mort et l'éternité et là
généralement ce que les personnes font
c'est un sablier et je vais terminer mon
intervention par une petite vidéo d'une
personnalité que j'espère
vous reconnaîtrez qui fait ce test et
vous verrez elle a ses propres réponses
avec le son un logo le cinquième sur les
chercher pour ça
[Musique]
des fois on peut sentir actionnaires
fâchée elle sochaux belchamp ce week end
ou de mort
vous voulez un disque à quand
[Musique]
et c'est le départ aussi présidente
irène s'enchaîner flammes
je suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de crosse aux besoins du marché en tête
elle nous voici tous doivent pouvoir et
de placer
et je terminerai par cette citation
en guise de conclusion de byron cathy
you are the one you've been waiting for
je pense qu'en considérant que vous êtes
vous même cette personne que vous
attendez en prenant soin de vous vous
réussir à d'une certaine manière ouvrir
votre champ des possibles revenir à une
vraie observations et prendre le large à
l'intérieur de vous même merci de votre
écoute
[Applaudissements]